everything is done with this very very
intimate personal
detail ever notice how the first few
minutes of a film can totally make or
break your viewing experience that's the
magic of the opening scene it sets the
tone introduces the characters
establishes the conflict and hooks the
audience's attention it's something that
for some reason stays with you so that a
few years later you can watch it again
or 10 years later you watch it again and
it's different some of the best films
out there have killer opening scenes
that stick with you long after after the
credits roll it's so much more fun to do
it in this video we're going to dive
into the first scenes of three wildly
different movies and see how they pull
off their cinematic Wizardry it is
simply an act of theater and don't go
anywhere because by the end of this
video you'll have a better understanding
of how to begin a movie and even be able
to write your own opening scene first up
though let's talk about the Dark Knight
a masterpiece from Christopher Nolan on
my films I try to shoot as much in
camera as possible now most sequels
start off by catching us up on what the
heroes been doing since we last saw them
often through narration or exposition
but the Dark Knight nope it flips the
script and introduces us to the bad guy
right off the bat embracing the golden
rule of Cinema show don't tell the movie
kicks off with a heart pounding bank
heist masterminded by none other than
the Joker our main antagonist filmed in
IMAX this scene pulls you right into the
action it starts with a sweeping shot of
the city then a window shatters in the
distance grabbing our attention we're
quickly introduced to a clown M robber
shooting a cable and another waiting on
the street holding a clown mask the
Joker Meanwhile the first group Zips
across the cable onto the the bank's
roof where they cut the phone lines
things really heat up when the main
group storms the bank guns blazing
causing total Pandemonium the high Sun
folds climaxing in a showdown with the
bank manager who manages to shoot one of
the robbers but then plot twist the
joke's been playing puppet master the
whole time setting up the robbers to
take each other out so he can snag all
the loot for himself in true Joker
fashion he Reveals His identity amidst
the chaos makes his Escape in a school
bus and leaves behind a scene of
Destruction and a classic Joker gag a
smoke grenade in the bank manager's
mouth this epic scene is is a perfect
intro to the Joker's character and his
key role in the film it showcases his
cunning his love for chaos and his
Psychopathic Tendencies it also sets up
the film's main conflict the ideological
and tactical clash between the Joker's
Anarchy and Batman's Quest For Justice
the scene uses cross cutting to build
suspense interlacing different actions
to ramp up the anticipation close-ups
draws closer to the characters and to
the action while a mix of sound effects
immerses Us in the chaos and let's not
forget Hans simmer score it uses
dissonance and Distortion to create a
sense of uneasy and impending chaos
where did you learn to count next up
we're Switching gears to a totally
different genre with Quinton Tarantino
and glorious
bastards this film's opening scene is a
whole different ball game it's all about
a tense chat between Hans Landa a
notorious Nazi officer known for hunting
Jews and perier ladit a French farmer
hiding a Jewish Family under his
floorboards unlike other films this
scene adopts a realistic and
naturalistic approach using long takes
and minimal cuts to immerse viewers into
the setting picture this a peaceful
country Countryside a car rolling up to
lapid's Farmhouse as L and his crew
arrive you can cut the tension with a
knife he is a detective that's first and
foremost where he's coming from he's a
detective the camera catches laad
dropping his wood chopping like a hot
potato and quickly signaling to his
family the interaction kicks off with L
and his men stepping into The Farmhouse
leading to a conversation that lasts a
solid 20 minutes the dialogue a mix of
French English and German keeps things
polite but oh so threatening and
everything scene he does is some version
of an interrogation and every piece of
interrogation is uh a piece of theater L
smooth as silk and sharp as attack
expertly pressures laad into spilling
the beans about the hidden Jews all
while pretending to care about his
family life at one point he asked for a
glass of milk which might seem innocent
enough but there's something creepy
about bad guys drinking milk it's like
they're twisting safe childhood memories
or hinting at some deep-seated trauma
think Alex in A Clockwork Orange or
homelander in the boys but hey maybe I'm
reading too much into the milk thing
let's get back to the scene laad caught
between a rock and a hard place tries to
play L but eventually cracks under his
Relentless questioning the scene hits
its peak when L switching to English to
throw off the hidden Jews forces the
truth out of lapad tragically Landa's
orders lead to the slaughter of the Jews
hiding under the floorboards except for
Shana a young girl who miraculously
Escapes in a shocking twist though L
known for his ruthlessness lets her run
bitting her a
chilling this intense scene is a killer
intro to L's character showing off his
cunning ruthlessness and manipulative
skills all of which have earned him the
nickname the Jew Hunter it sets up a
stark contrast between L and the film's
heroes the bastards a squad of Jewish
American soldiers taking out nais in
brutal ways plus the scene lays the
groundwork for the film's main conflict
the war between the Nazis and the allies
and Shana's quest for Revenge as she
later takes over a cinema set for a na
event the scene uses long takes to draw
us into the camera while medium shots
and close-ups make us feel more
connected to the characters strategic
sound effects like the car's arrival The
Chopping of the wood gunshots and the
massacre break up the Eerie silence
ramping up the scene's impact Ando moric
con's Melancholy music sets the mood
adding A Touch of Elegance and sorrow
the opening scene of Eng glorious
bastards is a masterclass in starting a
movie with suspense and dialogue it
introduces the main antagonist the main
plot and the main theme of the movie
while also creating a suspenseful and
captivating experience for us the
audience all right folks buckle up
because we're about to dive into a whole
new genre with Martin scores The Wolf of
Wall Street the opening scene is like a
high-speed roller coaster ride through
the wild and crazy life of Jordan
Belford our main man in the movie it's
all Quick Cuts and zooms designed to
keep you on the edge of your seat it's
kind of like a YouTube video we kick
things off with Jordan himself giving us
the lowdown via voiceover introducing us
to his identity and his company Straton
Oakmont then we're hit with a rapid fire
Montage of Jordan's over-the-top
lifestyle his mansion cars yacht women
and wild parties that's that's that's
the story we also get a glimpse of his
illegal and immoral Antics like throwing
a door D at a dart board or crashing a
helicopter the scene hits its peak with
Jordan saying I was making so much money
I didn't know what to do with it this
Whirlwind scene is another amazing intro
to Jordan pitting him as a greedy and
corrupt stock broker who rakes in
millions by scamming his clients he's
all about living the High Life spending
recklessly on anything that promises
pleasure and satisfaction with zero
regard for the consequences or the harm
he's causing others he's the polar
opposite of the FBI the movie's bad guys
I guess who are hot on his Trail ready
to bring him to Justice plus the sets up
the movie's main conflict the rise and
fall of Jordan's Empire Tangled Up with
the moral dilemas stemming from his
choices why bother telling a story of
somebody who's unremarkable even though
the scene doesn't fully embrace the show
don't tell concept it still manages to
deliver a potent mix of humor and shock
the clever use of VoiceOver narration
gives us a peak into Jordan's inner
thoughts and opinions while the Montage
technique stitches together a ton of
events creating a rhythm and energy that
packs a ton of info into a short span
sound effects from music to laughter
screams and snorts highlight the serious
and ridiculous aspects of Jordan's Life
The Eclectic music featuring various
artists sets the mood and tone often
commenting on or contrasting Jordan's
actions and words The Wolf of Wall
Street is a textbook example of how to
start a movie with a montage it sets up
the main character the main plot and the
main theme all while delivering a
powerful combo of humor and shock to
Reelin the audience so what can we learn
from these three opening scenes how can
we apply these techniques to our own
stories and films when you're planning
or writing your own opening scene here's
questions to consider what is the genre
and the tone of your story and how can
you use the opening scene to establish
those things who are the main characters
and what are their goals and motivations
how can you use the opening scene to
introduce them and make them more
interesting and relatable what is the
main conflict in the main theme of your
story and how can you use the opening
scene to set them up and hook the
audience's attention what are the
cinematic techniques that you can use to
enhance your opening scene how can you
use camera angles dialogue music editing
and symbolism to create tension suspense
humor or shock keep in mind your opening
scene is like your movie's handshake
it's the first impression and it's got
to be solid your goal is to Peak the
audien's Curiosity get them hooked and
make them feel invested in your story
but you know what the damn thing is you
got to be serious about making a
[Music]
picture